[Musica]
ognuno di noi è un dato
siamo dati cioè potenziale fonte di
informazione sempre in tutto quello che
facciamo e in fondo in un'epoca che è
stata definita era digitale
possiamo anche farcene una ragione e
perché no iniziare a viverlo come un
opportunità
perché se ci pensate non è così male
provate a ragionare su come la
digitalizzazione ha cambiato le nostre
vite nel modo in cui comunichiamo ci
spostiamo acquistiamo o fruiamo dei
servizi
certo spesso la digitalizzazione impone
alle nostre vite di esporre i nostri
dati a utenti terzi e questo a volte
vissuto con maggiore naturalezza e altre
meno vi faccio un esempio se io adesso
chiedessi a qualcuno di voi di
raccontarmi i suoi gusti musicali o di
dirmi che a questi ha fatto di musica
negli ultimi tre mesi dubito che
incontrerai una particolare a reticenza
giusto
le cose però forse cambierebbero un
pochino se iniziassi a chiedervi che
farmaci avete questa atto negli ultimi
tre mesi o da kim malattia e siete
affetti
la domanda è la stessa ma nel secondo
caso ci scatta qualcosa dentro è vero
perché perché quando si parla di dati
sanitari
c scatta dentro qualcosa che a volte
potrebbe essere vende scritta da termini
come perplessità
diffidenza se non addirittura
preoccupazione
cosa ne vogliono fare dei miei dati
ecco i motivi possono essere tanti ma
credo che questi siano i principali
abbiamo idee spesso molto confuse o
quantomeno nutrite di luoghi comuni su
cosa siano i dati e su come possano
essere utilizzati nel bene e nel male
in secondo luogo viviamo in una società
dove spesso è opaca la relazione che
intercorre tra le evidenze che arrivano
dai dati e come queste sono utilizzate
per prendere delle decisioni che poi
ricadono su ciascuno di noi e in ultimo
non abbiamo l'abitudine a valutare da un
punto di vista della rilevanza
statistica quello che ci accade e questo
unito al fatto che viviamo in una
società
interconnessa per carità ma
profondamente individualista ci fa
perdere di vista il fatto che la
valutazione dei rischi per la nostra
salute così come dei benefici è
fortemente dipendente dagli altri
ecco io vorrei usare il nostro tempo
insieme oggi per provare a fare
chiarezza su alcune di queste cose è
capire se possiamo convincerci che siamo
di fronte a un'enorme opportunità quella
di dotare cc cura e chiede cile per la
nostra salute di una specie di visione
aumentata della realtà quella che
l'analisi dei dati clinici può fornirci
e che la kent data science che oltre ad
essere il mio lavoro è la scienza che
studia i dati clinici è un potente
alleato è un'opportunità nella
costruzione di un futuro migliore per
ciascuno di noi
partiamo
se io dico la parola sanità digitale può
essere che ad alcuni di voi venga in
mente qualcosa del genere l'ospedale del
futuro in cui con un click compaiono
ologrammi che raccontano ai medici tutto
della nostra salute e li consentono di
prendere la decisione migliore per
curarci oppure la robotica che affianca
e da tempo sostituisce addirittura la
chirurgia di precisione
ecco quello che abbiamo in mente e
spesso tecnologia ma la tecnologia da
sola fa passi infinitamente più piccoli
di quelli che potrebbe fare se alla
tecnologia affianco assimo
sistematicamente la lettura e l'analisi
dei dati che di questa tecnologia per
altro sono spesso i primi figli
provo a spiegarmi con questo esempio
quello che vedete qui è il tasso di
mortalità nei 100 mila casi per tumore
al seno una delle grandi sfide della
medicina moderna
e vedete l'evoluzione di questa curva
nel tempo da quando sono state
introdotte le principali innovazioni
tecnologiche in screening diagnosi cura
quindi sia in prevenzione che nelle fasi
successive
ecco il momento in cui quella curva
davvero iniziato a scendere qualcosa è
davvero iniziato a cambiare è quando a
questa tecnologia
abbiamo iniziato ad affiancare la
conoscenza del dato genomico e quindi la
comprensione che c'erano profili
pazienti più propensi a manifestare la
malattia ma soprattutto che avevano una
diversa propensione a rispondere ai
trattamenti
l'unione di queste due cose ha fatto sì
che questa curva potesse essere
abbassata questa battaglia potesse
essere se non ancora vinta combattuta
con armi più forti
ecco questo credo faccia capire
abbastanza bene il potenziale dei dati
anche se non risponde alla domanda cosa
sono i dati clinici fiat e clinici sono
ovunque sono quelli delle cartelle
sanitarie elettroniche
quelli che sono raccolti nelle banche
dati amministrative che registrano ogni
nostro acquisto in farmacia con la
ricetta alla tessera sanitaria sono gli
esiti dei nostri esami del sangue sono
le immagini le pet e le tac gli
elettrocardiogrammi tutti quegli esiti
degli esami specialistici che facciamo
ma sono anche quelli raccolti quando
stiamo bene dalle app che continuamente
monitorando la nostra le nostre
abitudini alimentari
sportive o comportamentali
ecco è un'immensa mole di informazione
che racconta il nostro stato di salute e
cosa può dire questa immensa mole di
informazione a chi ci puro o chi decide
della nostra salute
niente
o meglio
niente da sola
perché molto di quella sgradevole
sensazione
che raccontavo prima deriva dalla mia
concezione che i dati possano parlare da
soli che i dati di hanno una visione
trasparente della realtà questo non è
vero
avere in mano dei dati e come possedere
un'enorme scatola di mattoncini
quello che ci faremo
dipende
da tante cose dalla chiarezza del
libretto d'istruzioni dalle domande che
faremo a quei dati dall'abilità dei
costruttori in un ultimo da quanti
mattoncini abbiamo è importante avere
informazioni relative a tanti pazienti
perché saremo più bravi a dare
previsioni precise rappresentazioni
precise che controllano l'incertezza dei
fenomeni biologici che osserviamo ma
neanche importante avere mattoncini di
qualità cioè che per ogni paziente sia
possibile ricostruire
quella grande fotografia fatta di tanti
pezzi
e che i suoi dati ci forniscono
ma anche qualora fossimo in grado di
fare questo e non è facile perché come
ben capirete i dati
sono in tanti luoghi diversi raccolti
con scopi diversi da persone diverse con
tecnologie differenti e questo è uno dei
principali problemi che oggi abbiamo
come ricercatori nel analizzarli
ma facciamo finta anche che si sia in
grado di raccogliere tanti dati il più
completo possibile
anche in questo caso i dati da soli non
direbbero nulla senza
qualcuno che sia in grado di estrarre le
informazioni che i dati contengono e di
trasformarla in conoscenza attraverso
un'elaborazione
conoscenza che possa essere comunicata e
trasferita su un piano decisionale
perchè un altro grande inganno è quello
per cui i dati prendono le decisioni
no i dati fanno parte di un contesto di
vincoli
economici politici
regolamentatori e perché no etici il
dato che siamo di salute e
la filiera che porta dai dati alle
decisioni è importante che sia chiara
trasparente comunicabile ecco se noi
riuscissimo a fare in modo oggi e non
siamo tanto lontani da questo obiettivo
di avere un percorso che lega una
raccolta dati
fatta bene
un'elaborazione e quindi una
trasformazione dell'informazione in
conoscenza per servire le decisioni ecco
io credo che di colpo nella
comunicazione di questo percorso quella
reticenza quella sfiducia
crollerebbe a favore di un clima di
fiducia di un desiderio quasi di
partecipazione ad un progetto del genere
e qui la domanda sorge spontanea come
facciamo a fare in modo che questo
diventi la prassi comune
serve un'azione
bilaterale in primo luogo serve che le
nostre istituzioni si impegnino
concretamente nella digitalizzazione
delle strutture sanitarie in modo tale
che i dati possano essere davvero
raccolti messi in interconnessione tra
di loro e siano resi fruibili in modo
uniforme sul territorio ovunque nello
stesso modo sembra sciocco da dire nel
2021 ma siamo lontani da questo
obiettivo
in secondo luogo serve un impegno
concreto a rendere questa informazione
accessibile a chi fa ricerca in modo
tutelato ovviamente in modo garantito ma
accessibile e infine serve che diventi
una prassi comune quella per cui in un
ospedale accanto ad un medico venga
assunto uno statistico un data santis
una persona che è in grado di lavorare
su quei dati e aiutare chi poi deve
prendere le decisioni
questo però è un desiderio programmatico
una cosa che inevitabilmente
impatterà il nostro futuro di medio
lungo periodo
cosa ciascuno di noi oggi può fare per
rendere questo disegno possibile e qui
veniamo all'altra direzione
innanzitutto con d i dati
condividerli il consenso informato e
credo il modo più noto ma non è l'unico
in secondo luogo siano chiamati ad un
cambio di mentalità profondo
innanzitutto in un'epoca chiamata era
digitale in cui pensate solo all'ultimo
anno e mezzo
quanta comunicazione viene fatta
attraverso i dati
deve sorgere con una necessità
imprescindibile il fatto di avere
un'adeguata alfabetizzazione al dato non
credo mi serva dire evento trombotico
profondo per evocare situazioni in cui
siamo stati chiamati a comprendere
qualcosa che forse non avevamo tutti gli
strumenti per comprendere un evento raro
capita in maniera casuale quindi sarebbe
potuto capitare comunque ho capita in
quanto c'è in associazione un altro
evento concomitante
ecco ci serve un'adeguata
alfabetizzazione per comprendere questo
tipo di fenomeni e in ultimo ci serve
fare un altro sforzo che è quello della
prospettiva con cui guardiamo alle cose
per ricordarci che i rischi per la
nostra salute così come i nostri
benefici dipendono profondamente dagli
altri e per farmi capire meglio userò un
esempio che non ha a che fare con la
sanità
io credo che sia condivisibile
come valore quello della mobilità cioè
il fatto che io uscendo di casa possa
prendere la macchina e raggiungere un
qualsiasi luogo e del paese
ecco forse ce lo dimentichiamo ma nel
fare questo
noi corriamo un rischio istat ci dice
che fino al 2019 c'erano circa 3 mila
incidenti all'anno sulle nostre strade
di fronte a questo dato di fatto ci sono
vari comportamenti possibili
io non prenderò mai la macchina per non
espormi a questo rischio oppure ma il
rischio è contenuto quindi io vado a 190
loro ovunque
tra questi due estremi diciamo che credo
tutti concordiamo c'è un comportamento
intermedio che è quello di chi si mette
macchina e guida con prudenza perché lo
riconosciamo come più ragionevole per
tutti i motivi che abbiamo visto fino ad
ora
si sono osservati dei dati che hanno
consentito di confermare l'associazione
tra un comportamento prudente e un minor
numero di incidenti
questo ha indotto un certo tipo di
regolamentazione
pensate ai limiti di velocità o al
sistema di tutor in in modo tale che la
gente fosse portata a comportarsi in un
certo modo
ma il rischio di fare un incidente
rimarrà davvero basso per me e per
chiunque si mette in macchina solo se io
e contestualmente chiunque si mette in
macchina guideremo con prudenza
questa è la prospettiva collettiva e
tornando al nostro esempio iniziale
questo significa che questa curva non
riguarda solo le pazienti malate di
cancro al seno e i medici che le devono
curare questa curva riguarda tutti noi
perché condividendo i nostri dati
noi consentiamo una migliore
comprensione di questo fenomeno anche e
questa è nostra responsabilità
quindi che cosa possiamo portarci a casa
oggi nel guardare alla realtà della
medicina personalizzata e della sanità
digitale con gli occhi dei dati
innanzitutto che noi siamo dati e questa
è una grande opportunità perché i dati
sbloccano le potenzialità della
tecnologia e aprono gli occhi di chi
decide
in secondo luogo che i dati non parlano
da soli
servono domande chiave per ottenere
risposte importanti servono competenze
servono i mediatori costruttori
e serve una maggiore alfabetizzazione
al dato e infine trasparenza nei
meccanismi che legano le evidenze alle
decisioni ma soprattutto serve un cambio
di prospettiva da parte di ciascuno di
noi
perché solo se ciascuno di noi accetterà
di farsi carico di un piccolo rischio
individuale ma che consenta in
definitiva migliore comprensione
il monitoraggio il controllo del rischio
collettivo
allora avremo fatto davvero un grande
passo avanti e l'avremo fatto insieme
verso la costruzione di una medicina
migliore quindi un futuro prossimo
migliore per ciascuno di noi
[Applauso]
[Musica]